everybody has that right to like protect
themselves or defend themselves most all
the people who hate Trump or pussies
they're not going to take to the streets
with guns we've got the guns is fear
what drives in the jority of concepts
does it promote gun sales of course it
does empower money money and power
[Music]
okay so we both got a ARS right now yes
and so we're gonna see the difference of
how they sound like we the suppressor
silencer one yep this is about as quiet
as it gets yeah yeah I mean right now I
don't even have headphones on no and
this sounds to me like a really loud BB
gun silencers have been highly regulated
since the National Firearms Act of 1934
was passed in the wake of the 1920s gang
wars but that may be about to change
that is it surprise you've seen
something like this what if a year ago
not today this is certainly now an issue
deregulating silencers is just one thing
that is likely to change in the next few
years just said to Wayne and I just said
to Kris I will not let you down the
National Rifle Association threw more
money behind Donald Trump's campaign
than any previous presidential candidate
and more than any pro Trump super PAC
congratulations mr. president
now the Trump era of gun rights is here
well the election of President Trump was
really bad for the cause of stopping gun
violence in this country we've been on
offense for the last four years here but
now we're gonna have to stop some really
bad things happening in the face of the
bitter hatred and elitist condemnation
this is our historic moment to go on
offense and defeat the forces that have
aligned against our freedom once and for
all
the NRA spent more than 30 million
dollars on Trump during the last
election she doesn't believe in your
right to keep a gun at home for self
defense the group aired nearly 11,000 TV
ads in four months before the election
much of that focused on swing states
don't let Hillary leave you protected
with nothing but a phone
but that wasn't always the nra strategy
the NRA you know has shifted its income
models so they figured out that they had
a problem gun ownership was radically
decreasing in this country you know half
of Americans own guns in 1978 and today
right around a third of Americans own
guns so the NRA in cahoots with the gun
industry helped change the model of the
industry to keep it alive to keep it
afloat to make sure that it could
continue to fund the NRA the NRA used to
be an enlightened organization that was
about protecting hunters protecting our
Second Amendment rights but then they
all were taken over by the gun
manufacturers and they became simply a
mouthpiece for profit these are you know
merchants of death at the end of the day
after wayne lapierre took over a CEO of
the nra in 1991 the organization became
more partisan Hillary would lie about
anything to get elected
gun owners care deeply about the guns
they owned and their future availability
to buy more of them they will vote for
you or against you on this single issue
for now expectations for Trump's
presidency are high among gun rights
advocates she's packing she's backing
larry pratt is executive director
emeritus of Gun Owners of America near
Washington DC it was out of character
for the NRA to be as engaged as early
and it's to their credit yeah now
they're just hoping that that investment
pays off I assume well they'll have a
lot of explaining to do while accepting
the NRA s early endorsement Trump used
the opportunity to speak about the mass
shooting in San Bernardino that occurred
the year before they killed 14 of their
co-workers and the co-workers thought
they were friends so there's something
going on after the attack Trump called
for a Muslim ban that he followed up
with an executive order during his first
days in office
we have no choice since the election of
President Obama there has been a pretty
slow methodical planful campaign of
Islamophobia in this country I think
Republicans and supporters of the NRA
generally are always trying to steer the
conversation away from guns President
Obama is trying to make terrorism into
guns and it's not guns folks it is not
guns mass shootings aren't only
political of course they also have major
ramifications for the public I met with
the family of Damien mines who died in
the San Bernardino attack it happened
because people with extremely dangerous
ideologies got hold of weapons that
could take people out very quickly and
it's you know people will insist that
this isn't a gun issue and they're right
it's it's the amalgamation of several
different issues if the fact of the
matter is is you know we might have 14
people still here today if they didn't
have those weapons I think the biggest
thing is like like I tell my own family
is don't live in fear paramedic and SWAT
team member Ryan Starling was one of the
first on the scene of the San Bernardino
shooting I just remember listening all
the radio traffic guys were driving down
copy the example we have 42 throughout
them went to the back door that day
could get here moans cries screaming it
smelled the Gunpowder active shooters of
new occurrence we really didn't have any
active shooter policies until after
Columbine there wasn't a need I mean
there's been prior cases before but not
to that extent mass shootings have
fueled gun sales with stock prices
jumping after each one
his fear would drive the majority of gun
sales does it promote gun sales of
course it does it can be fear of crime
it can be fear of the government
restricting them further there's a lots
of different kinds of fear
true to form gun sales surged after the
San Bernardino attack but Californians
also voted to pass one of the most
restrictive gun measures in the country
backed by California lieutenant governor
Gavin Newsom I also expect to see those
states like California punching above
their weight so the whole movement is
not dissimilar to marriage equality it's
gonna be a bottom-up movement not a
top-down after the election the NRA has
called on Congress to undermine state
laws like the one passed in California
if the anti-gun forces can get away with
sanctuary city type exclusions where
they unilaterally defy the rights of
American citizens then your Second
Amendment protections only exist if your
local government recognizes them in
addition to silencers the wish list for
gun rights advocacy groups includes
ending gun-free zones expanding
concealed carry allowing banned firearms
from overseas and deregulating sawed-off
shotguns in Los Angeles
I met with Sean Brady a lawyer who
represents the NRA in California he's
looking forward to the organization's
first steps under a trump presidency
concealed weapon reciprocity would be a
good thing another thing would probably
be what I like to call the hearing
Protection Act and that would be
allowing suppressors on firearms if the
hearing Protection Act is passed
silencers would be allowed to be sold
over the counter alongside guns at gun
shops
[Applause]
shortly before Trump was elected his son
Donald Trump jr. visited the CEO of
Silencerco a company that manufactures
silencers the CEO is a member of trumps
second amendment coalition of which
Donald Jr is the co-chair we talked
about the hearing protection act that do
you think that that's something that he
will sign we want to go through Congress
we want to do it the right way I met up
with Knox Williams head of the lobbying
group working to deregulate silencers
and rebrand them as suppressor we're
gonna do is show you the difference
between suppressed and unsuppressed
gunshots Knox was in Washington DC to
meet with the NRA but we were told we
couldn't come along the NRA didn't
respond to our repeated requests for
on-camera interviews do you think it's
got to get a lot easier I think it
potentially could we're working on the
hearing Protection Act and our goal is
to remove suppressors from the National
Firearms Act and treat them like any
other any other firearm that's the
industry's pitch it's not a tool for
spies and assassins there's some James
Bond shit right here instead it's all
about hearing protection the reality of
what these things do is they don't
eliminate the noise they mitigate it you
know these are mufflers for a firearm
these are the only thing also that's
gonna mitigate the noise at the source
why the hell you need a silencer and
these folks don't believe in
common-sense they don't believe in any
restriction I'm surprised they're not
advocating for private tanks with the
Republican president and a
republican-controlled Congress Knox's
group is firmly focused on passing
national legislation what's the purpose
of owning something like this um the
main thing is it just makes shooting
like a more pleasant experience it seems
to me like you just went through you've
got everything that you want yeah pretty
much but it you know it costs a lot of
extra money and a lot of extra time but
right now you've got a silencer slash
suppressor yeah you have one and it's
legal yep so what's the problem
um well if I wanted to get any more I
got to go through the process again
back in DC I asked senator Murphy why
the NRA has taken such a hard-line
stance on the issue
I don't read evil motives into the
hearts of the folks that run these
organizations or my colleagues who I
disagree with I think they are just
totally backwards in their belief that
we will make this country safer through
gun control Darwinism essentially
loading up everybody with weapons and
hoping in the end that the good guys
shoot enough of the bad guys if we had
guns on the other side it wouldn't have
been that way I would have boom if we
had guns on the other side it wouldn't
have been that way the gun has become a
symbol of far more than just the gun as
an issue in and of itself and therein
lies the power underlying this issue we
want to be significant we want to know
that we matter you care in a world where
you don't think I'm a tur and you don't
give a damn about me man having a gun
all of a sudden that makes me somebody I
asked the minds family about Trump's
claim that more guns would have helped
in San Bernardino so he was shot three
times before he could get down on the
ground and they were all fatal all three
of them so along with the other people
that were with him visit people do you
think it's just like ah so the selling
of a fantasy or that you like you could
stop this with your gun yeah I think for
some people it is for other people the
feeling of helplessness is is the worst
feeling in the world
what is this particular issue so
polarizing because a lot of money is
poured into this and we have groups that
are extremely well organized and play on
the fear of others across town from the
minds family I met up with yanli Burrell
who is once the editor of guns and a
Mose and guns magazine and the founder
of gun
world magazine we drum up crime in fact
I got rather sick of all these home the
fans kill the burglar articles yeah
because it was kind of about driving up
here to get people to buy more guns
right well yeah no my goal was to get
them to buy more magazine yong told us
that over the decades their articles
shifted from being about hunting and
marksmanship to a focus on home defense
survivalism and a distrust of government
romance has always governed a lot of
this and i think a lot of them these
guys who buy them imagine themselves
foiling some terrorist plot sort of like
bruce willis always does or did the
things of that sort
do you think that men buy guns to make
themselves feel powerful oh sure
well they feel powerful this is a
quintessential american issue it's about
having the power to over the state I
don't mind if the government fears the
people I think that's a good thing the
government ought to fear the people why
did you vote for John I never thought
much of Trump beforehand you know
reality show buffoon sort of him a
greedy egomaniac and whatnot other than
him when I began hearing him he made a
lot of sense to me
they spoke logic and truth I thought
yeah yeah and he was pro-gun
are you expecting any breakdown of order
nah because frankly if I can be crude
most of all the people who hate Trump or
pussies they're not gonna take to the
streets with guns we've got the guns our
full documentary series takes on issues
like the controversy over high-powered
assault weapons smart gun technology and
guns in schools make sure to check out
our entire series and subscribe to aj+
to watch more docs